is uh this is not your normal night here
jett no not at all um it would be even
different if he was playing oh yeah if
bill was playing i think that um you
know
the
i think philly fans are anxious to see
how good they are
more than what brooklyn is it's like no
we got our guys
we're here we're going to send a message
to you no matter when ben comes back
well you mean the team or the fans i
think the team and the fans no no no
that's not right i'm trying them fans
there for hatred yeah
they they all care about they don't care
about this game at all they're there for
one reason they're not even they're not
paying four thousand dollars for no damn
regular season games that's my point you
might be scared
it would even be
better if he was playing you know it
would be better from a basketball
standpoint but from from the from i mean
i'm not even sure
did he do that in any other game does he
go out there i mean he does before every
game okay
my favorite thing when i was playing i
used to watch you i used to love when
you say this game have
playoff implications and this game will
have player
implications it's a lot of things we're
going to be seeing this game james going
to show those two that yeah i made a
mistake i'm not the third fiddle i'm
going to show you the real james harden
tonight kyrie is going to show him
we're glad you're going kevin's going to
you know be showing i'm glad you're
going joel and b is still saying i'm the
best big man we're going to bust you up
but it would have been a better night if
ben was playing so
i give him credit for you know going out
there i wish he was playing would you
like to go
oh yeah yeah just back on and check it
out
i'm talking about with you personally
yes i would have gone i would have
played because they would have been
calling you a coward and every name in
the book he had to go you had to go and
i'm glad he went out there warmer and
i'm glad he's sitting on the bench yeah
because if he didn't it would have told
me a lot about him let's uh let's take a
look at carmax call your shot
and see what the sixers and the nets
have been up to recently and since the
trade
brooklyn four and eight
sixers eight and two sixers are 5-0 when
embiid and hardin played together
they've moved up to the number three
spot
actually a game in the loss column
better than the bucks who were number
two but the bucks have played three more
games
and
kyrie coming off a 50-point performance
the other night i mean see that's what i
tried to tell you guys the other night
what's that what makes this team so
dangerous
like
they got two guys they don't worry about
making the guys this is not a knock
they're so good offensively
if those two guys are on the court
brooklyn's gonna have a chance with or
without ben simmons those two guys
they're two of the best scores we've
ever seen in the nba
that guy had 50 points
and he's on like
and i i'm trying to figure out
how he gets in rhythm
like could you play
two days
take two games off of course
no
yeah it's great you didn't rest
no but yeah no this game ain't like
yours though you like getting luck dunks
and layups and shooting lane this guy is
dribbling or of dribbling around guys
shooting threes and everything like that
i think he is so incredible because
just answer my question could you play
i i really think that it's difficult
however i will agree with shaq you do
have an advantage certain nights where
you have fresh legs
everybody does it so like yeah because
we played in a different era so four
games and five nights and all that so
it's hard to really kind of compare it
uh but his skill set is ridiculous his
skill set in terms of scoring the
basketball and this era is probably
top by